hello everyone and welcome to round one
of the Tata Steel masters tournament
2020 it's a little safer ocean versus
Vladislav Kovalev and as usual the the
elite players will be joined by some
younger players this year the younger
players are a young shoe stove Duda
Jeffrey chunk and holidays of corrosion
here where is vladislav Korolev won last
year's Tata Steel challengers addition
and the so you own the rights to compete
in this year's a Tata Steel masters
edition so everyone's very interested to
see how holidays I will do as he just
won second place in the world rapid
championship so how much of that power
can heat transfer into the classical
time format so they're not oh well they
are raiding wise Ali Riza is over 27 28
27 26 and Kawhi deal is around 26 60
something so that being said let's check
out the game and as the title suggests
be very careful when memorizing your
opening moves well it is opens with E 4
we have e5 Knight f3 knight c6 and
Bishop to b5 the more sorry the rule
opus is on the board we have a 6 pushing
the bishop back and brush up the a4 more
fees defenses on the board we have
Knight to f6 and then our castles we
have Bishop to e7 rook to e1 and b5 so
all fairly standard stuff but should be
three we have d6 and c3 black castles
and here h3 taking away the g4 square
from blacks pieces and here Bishop to b7
equality goes for the floor sites of
system we have d4 byali Reza rook to e8
and now Knight B to d2 so this is all
standard theory we have Bishop to f8 and
now a for challenging black suspended
strong structure on the Queen side with
h6 and now Russia back to C 2 we have a
cat person B for C capture Sundy for end
night the b4 now attacking the bishop
here Bishop to be one not interested in
giving up the bishop pair just yet and
now as the the this c5 pushes possible
now as the knight has moved c5 attacking
white center we have d5 by allah des are
grabbing more space in the center
and this is where the magic happens so
this is a standard theory and here so
many games have been played in this line
Knight to d7 is the main idea after
which you will go rook to a3 and then
after this is played then you continue
with c4 and and so on and so on however
he record I decided to push c4 right
away and this this just won't to do its
he switched the move order so you have
to go Knight to d7 before this idea it
is immediately goes Knights to d4 and
now there is this threat of just pawn
captures and b5 pawn captures and you
win a pawn with Knight to b5 now there
is one game in the database where this
disposition actually occurred where
Queen to b6 was played we're black to
try to keep an eye on all the material
with the Queen the problem is after
Knight to to f3 Bishop to e3 is coming
and you will not have a good Square for
the Queen so here you will either have
to break break the tension with me
captures an a4 and mess up your Queen
side pawn structure which is terrible
since you will have very very weak
points on the Queen side and well it's
it's just as I understand it it's a
strategically one position for white so
in that game g6 happened and then just
Bishop to e3 you no longer have a square
for the Queen you either have to move it
or or or do some Knight captures on d5
craziness but either way Kovalev did not
go for Queen to b6 instead he went
Knight to d7 now so literally switching
the move order and Alireza just captures
the pawn a capri-sun b-58 captures on b5
route characters and a 8th Bishop
captures and now Knight captures on b5
now there is a there is a chance that of
course this was some sort of an
elaborate pawn sacrifice
however called have took some half an
hour I don't know if it was in this
exact same position but around here I
took some half an hour think after after
he was down upon so I don't think it was
home preparation
all in all Queen to b8 attacking all it
is is knight Knight back to a3 and now
Kane Knight to d3 you get this excellent
square and if for example there
for Sundy 3c captures okay that could be
could be an interesting point
however ali reza just goes look the III
now threatening Bishop captures captures
and winning yet another pawn and there
really is no good way to defend against
this since even if you do nothing the c4
pawn will fall as well and all of whites
pawns are nicely protected so here for
for the lack of a better move quality we
decided to capture on c1 we have Queen
captures on c1 and lounges g6 saying
that okay I'm good I'm gonna put my
bishop on this long diagonal I still
have the bishop pair however I'm down
two points so all it is a captures on c4
with Bishop to g7 and now look back to
a3 preparing to consolidate would be for
Bishop is coming to d3 and so on
so Queen to c7 by kovalev and b4 now
that's a passed pawn so of course Ali
Reza starts pushing it with brush up the
b7 and now Bishop to d3 consolidating
with rook to b8 and now a Queen to d1
coming to f3 with with ideas that maybe
you can get some rook to a 7 action in
and the Queen from f3 could also post
threats on the f7 pawn so Bishop to see
it not not allowing this very nice rook
lift but now Quinta a4 we have Knights
the e5 and here are these others are
just captures he loves this chick but
it's a it's not really at the greatest
of checks so Queen the c1 check he
blocks with the bishop asking do you
wanted this night or or this night of
course II five 9s captured but captures
an e5 and now just Knights the c4 and
this is an excellent outpost for the
night the Queen doesn't really have all
that much to do even though she's on a
such a lovely square and the rook will
have a lot of problems entering the game
so Bishop the d4 Ocoee will now try to
create some threats against the f2 pawn
but Quinta EA trick King the g7 and now
rook the f3 going after the f7 pawn here
f6 the Bishop nicely-nicely defends it
but now Queen to e7 check Val it is a
weave King to g8 and here of course ali
reza played Queen to d8
trick
and it was in this position unmoved 36
that vladislav could have resigned the
game as he well severe material loss is
about to happen which I'm sure you all
see just in case you don't you know you
are even welcome to pause the video to
figure out why black resigned but I'm
sure all we saw it so I'm just gonna
congratulate you because after the king
moves king g7 King h7 King give seven
over ever you move the King doesn't
really matter
27 check picks up the rook and you don't
have you don't have any threats here the
the knight is nicely guarded by the
bishop the regards DF to pawn there are
no tricks it's just game over for black
so a fairly easy win in round one for
Alireza
and although some of the games are still
being played it's hard to say if any
other games will be decisive but we will
definitely check the elite players drew
their games fairly early so it wasn't a
very eventful first round but Alireza
you know takes what he is given perhaps
a little a little something back for for
losing that position to Magnus sometime
in the in the world blitz championship
so maybe you know Caixa smiled on him to
you know to pay him back for that but
either way you know be very careful when
memorizing your openings as something
like this can it can happen very easily
even if you were to 826 60 plus a
grandmaster as a lot of slavko a live
here is so that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it a lot of stuff I'm sure
didn't I would like to thank Mario
Encino Octavian Lodi on Donald Schwing
George Taylor and Jacko beat for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot to really appreciate it as usual you
can check - on my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
Tata Steel masters edition perhaps even
the Challenger edition if there will be
some nice games and we'll be checking up
on the Women's World Chess Championship
so thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day